بملامحها قاسيه لم تنسيها طفولتها كراعيه
اغنام وباعقل وازن يضعها على عرش صناعه
التعدين نجحت جنرال هارت الملياردير
الاستراليه في بناء امبراطوريه اعمال كبرى
في بلادها وجمع ثروه تقدر بس 26 مليارا
و600 مليون دولار كما باتت اغنى شخصا في
استراليا وسادس اغنى امراه في العالم فما
قصتها ولدت
جورجينال هارت عام
1954 في استراليا الغربيه وهي لبنه
الوحيده ليلانج هانكوك وهو راعي الماشيه
اصبح احد اقرب صناعه التعدين بعد اكتشافه
تربه غنيه بالحديد بمنطقه في المباراه غرب
استراليا في عام
1952 اسس لاند شركه هانكو بروستينج وبدل
جهودا مضنيه للعثور على زعمين لت لمنجم
خام الحديد الخاص به حتى تمكن من ابرام
اتفاقيه ملكيه مربحه مع عملاق التعدين
البريطاني الاستراليه ريو تانتو ليبدا
مصيده ناجحه بسوق التعدين خلال فتره نمو
الشركه كان هانكوك يصطحب جنى معه دائما
فحضرت وهي طفله اجتماعات العمل في جميع
انحاء العالم درست جنى الاقتصاد لفتره
وجيزه في جامعه سد ولكنها تركت الدراسه في
عام
1973 لتصبح المساعد الشخصي لوالدها ويده
اليمنى بعد وفاه والدته جنى تزوج والدها
من روسيا وهي مربيه فلبينيه كانت قد
وظفتها لتدبير المنزل
الجديده كما تورط في سلسله من المشروعات
التجاريه غير الحكيمه وهو ما ادى لتوتر
العلاقات بين الاب وابنته توفي
عام
1992 فاصبحت جنى رئيسه تنفيذيه لشركه
هانكوك بروسبكتينجا التي كانت تعاني انذاك
من ديون كبيره كما كان عليها خوض معارك
قانونيه مع زوجه ابيها امتدت لاكثر من 10
اعوام للحصول على ارثها من والدها نمت
المجموعه تحت قياده جنا لتصبح من انجح
شركات التعذيب الخاصه عالميه ووسعت
استثماراتها لتشمل النحاس والبوتاس والذهب
والفحم والماشيه ومنتجات الالبان
والعقارات في عام 2010 و2011 حازت جنى على
لقب اغنى امراه في استراليا كما كانت في
عام 2012 اغنى امراه في العالم عندما كانت
ثروتها تقدر بنحو 30 مليار دولار حاصله
على الدكتوره الفخريه من جامعه بوند وهي
ايضا مؤسسه لمنظمه الاسرائيليين للتنميه
الشماليه والرؤيه الاقتصاديه
دي ايفيا وقد الفت كتابين في مجالات
الاعمال والتعدين وهي تحضى بمكانه
المرموقه ببلدها وحازت على عدد كبير من
التكميمات والجوائز تملك جنى التي كانت
ترعى الاغنام في صغرها اليوم ثروه تقدر بس
26 مليارا و600 مليون دولار لا يمكن القول
انها فقط كانت وريثه نجاح والدها بل ربما
كانت الشريكه التي حافظت على الارث الكبير
وطورت هذه الامبراطوريه
وقادتها بجداره
[موسيقى]